okay so in the embryonic version
i stopped the cut um
as spooky
so i don't want to be in a full-blown
cutting
posture okay so we
we go
i'm going to come in boom
here i'm in transition
so my normal cut would be here boom
then i would be back in hungary
so here boom
here i'm in the middle of what would be
the cut
so i show the middle of that cup
when i do my cut don't flex your wrist
it's the same cut shoulder cut
boom on my wrist don't flex
no cut wrist does not flex
wrist does not flex
same wrist up
down the whole way up down
no no
oh my so my hands will end up
about shoulder height and i'll be in the
position
let's go back
shoulder height about an inch off of his
wrist
and i'm in a transitional stance
okay let's go okay so these these
wrist flexions are
uh performance allowances because
bulking are so much lighter
than the sword is so you can do this
stuff you can come up
and you can go like this
or the guy is not attacking me
so when i when i do this move he doesn't
feel like well that's really quite an
opening
okay but there's another one
when you come to cut is your hands move
on
on the weapon you go like this you're
down here
you have a lot of space here remember
this technique
weight is supposed to be on the tip so i
have a tsuba on this sword
so you can see that
as i go back my hands are there
i come in boom and my hands stay there
they're in the same position it doesn't
keep sliding
don't have your hands come back to this
grip here
okay the reason that's happening is
there's a kind of
naggy relationship with the sword and
you're fighting the sword so it's
pulling on
what you're pulling and you're losing
the battle
and that's how your hands slide
there is a timing that you have to have
between your hands
and the movement of the sword so i'm
kind of
just riding the sword just like i would
a uke
i'm not pulling and yanking on the sword
that'll almost always make this kind of
stuff happen
okay so we'll do it again
and keep your meds you go
another beginner mistake you're looking
at the target
you're cutting high and you come up high
with your stance
keep those down slow
and i'm not looking at the target my med
scan the form
is captured per the form at the upper
throw side cavity here
not looking at the target okay
i now hit him in the midst of his
cut for the uk
usually the beginner is like you just
have to do your cut
okay if your chemi can't do that
stay embryonic
same thing all the alignments there i
have a front hip
i have a front shoulder it's an
alignment with my nose
and it's in alignment with his spine and
it goes through his center on the atos
let's go
so
uh
[Music]
kia you might want to sue bye
really though the only authentic reason
for the suga
is when the nage is worried about hating
you
you can get them to have more of the
cutting spirit if they think that
there's a tsuba there
but it's it's all imagination because
the suba doesn't really protect the
hands
you can protect the hands okay so
he's gonna be in jordan and i'm going to
do the cut we're going to go slow
hold slow so slower
so he goes so here comes the cut
i'm going to feel that initial contact
and that's what starts to drop my center
so if i feel the contact
and i am staying up it will go into my
shoulders
and that will provide the resistance
that he needs to cut
me or in this case hit me okay
secondly look at what he's cutting
he's cutting the right hand so don't let
go of the left hand
if you want to let go of the hand it's
the right hand
absorb
thicker
you keep moving this way
now as i come in
that he never touches the right hand
okay
so we'll do the technique
okay now on to the complete form
so we're going to walk into sega
and that adds your your measuring okay
uh you're gonna hold the sword at this
kind of neutral position
so this would be threatening but this
is uh not threatening so here at that 45
degree angle
and you walk and you time it and you hit
sega then the guy goes forward
he goes and you do the same exact move
now i initiated so i continue initiating
i'll come back
and you repeat repeat repeat okay